okay good morning everyone
welcome to this free webinar
today's webinar is going to be dedicated
to the program called
omix logic data science and our mix
logic is a
company that brings together
participants from all over the world
welcome to this free webinar okay
okay sorry about that i had to unmute
the other one so let me
resume so omex omixlogic
is a training program developed by
pine biotech which has been started as a
technology transfer company
from the university of haifa from the
tower bioinformatics research
center there at the center the team is
focused on developing
novel algorithmic approaches to
multi-omics data integration
and we have a team that works on
translating that research platform to
practical use in many different areas
of molecular medicine genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and other
types of omnix data
but as a result of this we have
developed a program that is now being
used
by thousands of people from around the
world and multiple universities and as a
result we have trained
a number of students and researchers to
utilize some of the resources to
elevate their level of bioinformatics
and provide with excellent support to
use big data
in various areas of research so
pharmexlogic
is essentially a program that provides
training in bioinformatics that enables
independent research that is guided by
mentors and peer example
and we are developing a growing
community with shared passion for data
driven research and
appreciation of citizen science so not
only uh
researchers that are already doing
research but also those
that are interested to do that and are
interested to do that even
without a deep expertise that they
already possess
and our goal is to enable students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using the
latest technology in
life in data science and so what we've
realized
over the course of these programs is
that data science
plays a central role in the ability
to extract meaningful insights
from biomedical and biological data
and as a result we identified the need
to provide
training in statistical analysis and
machine learning
design of experiments how to
properly design them to get the right
kind of information
including elimination of technical
variation and provide
tools and skills in data mining for
meaningful patterns and associations
between phenotype and genotype at
multiple omics levels
and to study complex biological systems
using big data so the goal of this data
science program
is to really introduce the participants
to various
types of omics data including different
technical formats and data types
and file formats and what are the
specific
challenges to translate those raw data
formats to
structured data formats to learn about
exploratory data analysis and the steps
of
processing data in preparation for
downstream analysis so how to
actually use the information that is
structured and prepared and what kinds
of considerations we should
have before we start the analysis itself
introduce the participants to big data
analysis tools for large scale
project data and to try different
methods
of machine learning in r and python
and then to learn the important links
between data and biology
so how to interpret the found patterns
linking the methods that were used to
analyze the data
with biologically meaningful insights
who is this program for so the program
is really for
anyone with an interest in biological
data
and specifically in all mixed data
including students from high school
colleges universities but also for
biologists and clinicians that have
some kind of research work that is
probably acquiring more
and more characteristics of a data
science project and what is a data
science project essentially
a data science project is a project
that requires in-depth understanding
of data how it was generated what does
it represent
what is the context of the project
itself it also requires to
wrangle and process that data so
oftentimes we start from a dump
of data whether it is raw sequencing
reads
or all kinds of notes about something so
it's really
unorganized information and the
final part of it is that there's a
challenge and the challenge
is to work through all of this mess
and translate that into something
meaningful meaningful can mean
visualization so that the visualization
visually the data is summarized in the
proper way
it could also mean that we are going to
take some biological experiment that
can be viewed through multiple different
perspectives and we need to understand
what do all of these perspectives mean
and that means data integration and also
it can mean
we can train some kind of a machine
learning model to
help us understand what happens in a new
data set based on a data set we've
already explored so
we'll talk about all of these components
but i think that all of them are
relevant
for students that are learning about
this or for practitioners those that are
already
using this kind of data in their
research
and uh to really um introduce all of
these topics
uh we have our team here which is myself
dr
mazumber and dr aprica or but we also
have
one of the mentors that will be joining
specifically to
walk us through some of these technical
elements of data science and to
introduce them
i would like to pass it on to clinton
kunha
um clinton welcome
thank you ilya so i will introduce
myself through another amazing
powerpoint
um i'll just share my screen uh
could i have permission to
share my screen
in fact
all right let's yes
perfect thank you elia
so hello everyone my name is clinton
i studied at the
at carnegie mellon university for my
bachelor's degree in
biological sciences i did an honors
degree there
and i also did two master's degrees
one in molecular medicine that's wet lab
research
and another one in dry lab research so
bioinformatics
i've learned several skills along the
way such as python
r uh linux programming and um
i've won some awards in different
institutions
um i also have a software engineering
diploma and i do love
i love both biology and programming
so just a little bit about my background
my first masters was about studying a
protein known as t20 like kinase
or slk and this was in a cancer lab
where we studied different cell lines
some mouse models essentially we were
working on characterizing
slk's role in apoptosis cell cycle and
cell migration
some common cancer phenotypes
and some things that we found out were
that it's critical
in normal development and a complete
knockout
lethal and it plays a role in
new induced memory tumor genesis
so breast cancer in mice
so that could have a phenotype a human
phenotype for future projects
so these are just some results if you're
used to wet lab
techniques you might be familiar with
western blots
and focal adhesion assays so
the aim was to find out what slk do
the role of slk or c20 like kinase
in mouse embryonic fibroblasts by
testing
common cancer processes such as
proliferation migration and apoptosis
and finally the result was that
we noticed that focal adhesion turnover
seems to be impaired
so i did i studied this at the
university of ottawa
where i did my first masters
so after doing my wet lab research
within a cancer lab i i felt like
i wanted to learn more analytical skills
to analyze my data set so
looking at the trend around me i noticed
that
biology was heading towards a more data
science approach more where you have to
analyze different types of data
with more sophisticated software tools
so then i realized that let me
transition to
a more bioinformatics role and i joined
another masters immediately after my
first in
um in the university of guelph so i did
a masters
in bioinformatics and some of the
reasons
why i did that was because of the the
changing dynamics of the field
my passion for both biology and
programming
i did get into computer science at
carnegie mellon for my bachelors
but at the time i was more interested in
biology
and i never really uh knew much about
bioinformatics or computational biology
so i because of that i got exposed to
different disciplines such as statistics
uh mathematics engineering computer
science
something that a person who just did
biology
might not generally be exposed to so it
did give me
a lot of variety and i did enjoy that so
it was very
and i still enjoy it
so after doing my master's in
in bioinformatics um i i came across
i met elia through one of his uh
interesting webinars and i he was
talking about his
um bioinformatics for precision oncology
program
and we were discussing about the
different aspects
and um i i had the opportunity to
uh be one of the mentors for the program
um i'm currently doing a
teaching and training of adult
certificate expected in august
so i do have the formal teaching skills
to embark in such a program and
and it was very it was a very nice
experience because i have
i have the interest for cancer research
and it was very enlightening to see my
students with their own research
coming from a more wet lab approach
which is something i'm familiar with so
it was a very
i had the opportunity to talk to
research what lab research scientists
give them my
insights use the resources that we have
to
help improve their research by
incorporating
important data science techniques
but for this program it was particularly
data science techniques for cancer
research
but the program that we're
talking about is more the important
software skills
for more generic types of research so
these techniques are very important and
being a person who
transitioned from a what lab approach to
a dry lab approach
i can definitely appreciate those
techniques
and this was a fun experience and i hope
and i look forward to
repeating the same with you all
so that is does anyone have any
questions
so clinton i actually do have a question
for you
uh i'll represent the audience here
so my question is how difficult was it
to transition from learning about
lab sciences and biology to data science
or to
you know other things that you've done
so
initially i thought it might be very uh
difficult um because there were some
programming concepts like like r
was a bit new to me i did a little bit
of python in
i did some python in my bachelor's
degree but uh it was minimal
i think with every new experience you
you kind of have
there's a learning curve so no matter
what you do you will have
some sort of learning curve and you
most people have to go through it um
thankfully
you know being in a good environment so
you know being in this course you'll
have experienced mentors to give you
that learning environment
just like my professors during my
master's program
so every i'd say in my experience
every challenge has a learning curve
it's preferable to have a good learning
environment and good mentors to help you
support
to support you during that learning
curve
and another question that i wanted to
ask was
how do you know when you've learned
something i mean how
many there are many resources online
right you can just download people's
code and you know try it and things
like that i mean how do you know that
you've actually learned
some analytical technique or method
so um because i
am i am in the process and i i have been
an
instructor uh there is a taxonomy
it's called bloom's taxonomy so they're
different levels
of learning so it depends on how
much depth you want to go into so you do
have a point that sometimes you might
not
be sure if you learned something and
educators like to use
concept checking questions uh different
types of assessment
uh whether it's coding assessments
or just simple quizzes or multiple
choice questions
um it's usually good to display your
work in a
in a project of some sort so
um that really shows that you've
mastered the
the tiny puzzle pieces in order to
create your own novel work
so that would be one of the higher
levels on that taxonomy
versus just you know typing a print
command
which just kind of shows you that you
you you memorize the recall so you have
that recall stage
so ultimately demonstrating
your work in a creative project that
would show like
your ultimate understanding so through a
research project
so whether that's publishing or doing
presentations
in front of other experienced people or
creating some manuscript or doing a
poster
so yeah okay great
thank you very much and if you do have
any other questions please do write them
in the chat box and we'll be sure to
address those
and i briefly want to pick it up from
where
clinton has left off to talk a little
bit about
what are some of the challenges and
opportunities
especially applying this type of skill
the technical computational programming
you know data science skills to big data
so the first thing that i would start
with is that
surprisingly we have access to
a lot of high quality data sets not only
are these data sets
generated by experts in excellent labs
the data sets continuously update so we
have
new and more detailed understanding of
different
areas of life sciences through the lens
of these
data for example just in this pandemic
we have a tremendous growth not only in
the quantity and quality of data but
also the rate of data submission so
if you compare this to previous
pandemics like
the sars one ebola virus mers or zika
this pandemic has generated so much data
in almost real time
and has made that data accessible to
almost anyone that would like to now the
question is not so much about
data availability but what to do with
this data
to extract meaningful insights and
that's where i think
these skills really come together so
first of all data could be
of many different types it could be
imaging data
clinical data streaming data comics data
chemical phenotypic there
are really many different types of data
but for all of them
one of the first challenges is to create
structured
data that you can actually work with and
so
to do that the first thing that we will
talk about is how to take these
different types of
data including phenomics phenotypic data
genomics
variant data epigenomics different types
of histone modifications
dna methylation transcriptomic data gene
expression and things like that
and how to take that information and
start processing it
creating structured tables and those
tables
could come in different formats they
could be matrices
with just numbers they could be data
frames with both numbers
and different types of levels for
factors
or names and now that we have
the structured data now the second
challenge
is really to be able to ask the right
kinds of questions about this data right
nobody just takes data and
structures it so that you can you know
visually see what's in it
right everybody works with data to be
able to answer some important questions
and that's another
part of data science that i think
differentiates a data technician from a
data scientist the science
is really all about asking questions
that are supported by evidence
and so the data exists to help us
extract evidence from the data set
but for us to have a relevant question
what we want to do in this program is to
introduce you to some of those critical
and important interesting questions
that could be asked of these types of
data sets so that you can really
utilize the data effectively and so what
we hope
that this program can provide for you is
a complete roadmap for data science that
will be an application to biomedical
research data
but it will include things like finding
different data sets
learning how to explore and visualize
these data sets to understand
major characteristics of the data how to
understand different types of research
methods that others use
and extract the evidence that you need
to answer a research question
and ultimately how to showcase or
illustrate what you have found with
relevant
methods of insights so that you can
visualize your data so that you can
identify
the properties the statistical
properties to point to and
ultimately lead to understanding so
we call this program ominix logic
because
really it combines the omics data and
the
practical skills with a logical approach
and it guides you from a to b
from knowing about all of these terms
and wanting to apply them
to actually understanding of how to
apply them and then demonstrating what
you have learned
so we'll take several different types of
projects
using biomedical omnics data from
diagnostics in cancer biology
single cell and tissue composition
microbiome and infection
and in the context of these different
types of topics
we will learn about your typical data
analysis
skills that you would have to learn to
use effectively to extract meaningful
insights
including data collection so how is the
data collected
what does it represent data cleaning
how do you extract only the relevant
information
or the good quality data right
and make it tidy and ready for analysis
how to perform exploratory data analysis
and how to iterate that process so that
the insights
come from the data data driven questions
and hypotheses that you can generate and
then how to
explore the data in in a way that you
can really
apply statistical modeling and inference
from
those models so that you can get
meaningful results
and obviously a big part of that is
going to be focused on
data mining in classification so we will
learn about
different types of unsupervised and
supervised techniques
that have been used extensively on their
own
but also as a part of meaningful
bioinformatics work
and the principles of data science
that include statistics and data
wrangling are going to be very
meaningful
here when we go to machine learning
because you will essentially
operate with an extraction from
different portions of the data
to train your model to validate your
findings
to make sure that your model is accurate
and
you will learn to differentiate between
different types of methods
so that you can compare and contrast the
results and select the ones that are
most appropriate to the type of
problem that you're solving now the same
methods are
also included in many different types of
biological data mining and those include
things like differential gene expression
or principal component analysis
and standard tools that are adapted from
these methods to
address more and more technical
variation and complexity
in the types of data that is being
collected including
integration of multinomics data but also
including
more and more advanced data types like
single cell
data and data that combines multiple
elements together
and so that's why we really are going to
be looking at
a variety of applications for
multi-omics data integration and
integration of this
omics data with clinical data using the
different examples that we will try
so to give you an overview of what this
program is going to
look like i would like to take you to
the program page so
uh for all of you involved uh
sorry let me go over here
okay so um everyone that is
interested to join this program the
easiest way
to show you what this program is going
to include
is to take you to the program page so
this is a
program page it is called lb rn omix
logic data science
and so i'll just explain what is lbrm
mean lbrn stands for louisiana
biomedical research network our major
partner in this program
and the because of their support we are
able to make this program more
accessible to more people
and so the types of information that you
will
get on this page are going to i think
address many of the questions that you
might have
joining today's webinar so first of all
the program is going to start on july
12th
and last for a month and during this
time we will
cover a number of different topics by
participating in live sessions like
today
where you can interact with the mentors
and get answers to your question
as well as practice in class to perform
different types of analysis
you will also be able to
use a synchronous resources in between
our sessions
to gain more technical skills
at your own flexible schedule so in many
cases we will
go through a portion of the material by
going through them in our session and
then we will point you to resources that
you can
supplement this knowledge with by
performing actual technical steps
of writing the code trying to run the
code
getting the outputs and even
troubleshooting some of your results
so to illustrate how that part of it
will work
well let me ask you how many of you
already have an account
on omixlogic so please if you do
have an account uh maybe you can put in
number one
in the chat if you okay great thank you
leanna
if you don't have an account just take a
minute to register
the way you register is you go to login
and you create an account right here on
this form
after you've created the account you
will have access
to the coursework that we will discuss
okay great excellent so i see that a lot
of you already have this
and once you're logged in you will be
able to see
yes you will be able to see some of the
courses that are
going to be included in this program
okay so is there anyone
here that have not
registered yet
is there anyone here that has not
registered yet
okay if you could take a moment and
register please we'll give it just a
couple of minutes
so everyone is able to follow through
some of the examples
that we will be going through
okay so once you are logged in
you will be redirected to a page where
you see a collection of courses
that are linked to your profile and what
i will demonstrate
is how we will leverage some of these
resources to actually
practice what we are going to do in this
program okay so i
see that someone is raising their hands
would you like to ask something
okay okay so
um if you're already inside
on the course page
please search for data science
and you will see here a couple of
courses
data science introduction to data
science and python and an introduction
to data science in r
okay so once you are in these courses
you will be able to see what types of
methods we're going to be covering
and even try some of them with a free
registration so
if you register today or you already
have been registered before
you can access all of the free courses
and then
when you complete your registration and
there's a number of ways that you can
register that i'll talk about
you will see courses with this star and
those would be premium courses that
address some of the more advanced topics
and require some more practice
so you'll be able to access those with a
premium subscription
one of the things that is always
difficult
with large complex data sets is to grasp
the type of information or the type of
relevant
information that is in the data quickly
not spending a lot of time on individual
feature
like a gene and more looking for general
trends so what i want to show you today
briefly
is an example from a course on
dimensionality reduction
principle component analysis and
visualization
now principal component analysis is most
useful for continuous data which means
that
the data is in a numeric form
just like you see inside the cells over
here
and it could be anywhere in a continuous
scale
from zero to whatever the maximum is and
it doesn't even have to be zero it could
be also centered so it could be
minus one to one or it could be negative
and positive numbers but the key point
here is that it is continuous data
and so the continuous data is
represented here in this example
as a gene expression profile for
a number of different groups as you can
see right here we have
a row for groups and we have
sample ids which are essentially names
of cell lines
that have different properties so they
come from different breast cancer
patients
and so using this example what you'll
see in this course
is how you can apply a principal
component analysis technique to quickly
evaluate the separation of samples
into different groups based on this
gene expression profile that is found
inside the
data matrix which is just the numeric
portion of this table of this data frame
that we were looking at just a moment
ago
so you have a brief video that you can
go through to really understand the
challenge of the process to getting to
this outcome but also you have a
breakdown of the full code now for many
people including myself
one of the main challenges in learning
data science
is that most of the courses out there
start with
very basic things like learning how to
print out hello world
in our case we're assuming that you are
ready to jump beyond that
and start with a data set that you
understand and that's why we've selected
these data sets that come
from a background relevant to life
sciences
and so i think many of the people are
more
motivated to continue and learn about a
method once it's
talking about a data set that you
understand so in this case this is gene
expression
for cell lines and those cell lines
could be categorized
in groups based on their type or subtype
of breast cancer
and so the first thing that you will see
here are some
important parts of the code that you
have to master
for any kind of a script and in this
case
we have different libraries that will be
used
and these libraries include libraries
which are packages that
include many different functions that we
can pull from
to actually apply to the data set that
we load
the second line here is going to be how
to load this data
so this data exists here on the internet
but how do i put it into the script
right and so that will be there and then
we start working with this data set
to extract only the meaningful portion
of the data
for our analysis and then launch the
analysis now once you learn these
brief steps it's very easy to understand
how we can apply the same technique to
many different types of data
and how to start working with the tables
so here you see some two different
methods the base
method in r and the g plot method in r
for visualizing this data and as you go
through
some additional useful information is
going to be added to the plot
like labeling the plot or even
projecting
the feature significance or how
individual genes
contribute to this principle component
analysis
plot a two-dimensional plot that we're
looking at
so that we can evaluate which genes are
actually responsible
for the separation into different groups
so once you go through some of this
basic explanation in learning the code
you will be able to
try the code yourself and trying the
code
starts from just simply pressing this
button
run okay so just by running this code
right here in the browser
you already get some output and you can
play with this
to change things so that you can see
what is actually going on for example
as you're going through this code
you can see that we can take there are
actually two different methods to
visualize the pca
output output so here you have the basic
method with plot
and here you have a uh
gg45 so a library to do everything in a
different approach
and simply by deleting this
we can try to run it again
and only get the basic plot right so now
we can separate the plot
into portions that we understand so we
understand what
the first portion did we understand what
the second portion did
in order for me not to forget i can just
reload the full script
and get all of the things that were in
there before so i can actually now
remove this part of it right here
run it again
and only get the gg plot output right
so now i'm working with two different
libraries one is the base library
including in
r and another one is a library called
gg45
that i can actually look up online and
see
what does it do right so i can start
looking into all of the different
options for ggfortify
and see what does it do and many of the
experiences that you will have applying
data science
is going to be related to looking at
different packages
and seeing what kinds of additional
methods are going to be used
and how are these methods actually used
by others
to use for example for principal
component analysis so you can always
find these packages on their different
repositories online
okay a question from abubakar can you
run the code with your own data
excellent question so this is
a code that is going to work anywhere
right so simply taking this code
right here and copying it to your
clipboard
you can now install r and r
studio on your own computer and run this
code
on the data set that you would like to
analyze
however let's take a look at how this
data was loaded
you can see that the input file is given
via
a url this is a url to a
github repository where we store all of
the data sets that we'll be going
through
on your computer that data set is going
to be sitting somewhere else it's going
to be in your folder
but in a very similar way you're going
to be using the path
instead of a url to a public domain
you'll be using a path on your own
computer and you can do that
by setting up a working directory on
your computer
and then linking to that directory not
through the full path but just giving
the name of the file
so that's something that you can try and
you can also try some of these
downstream codes that are going to be
much
more detailed in what kinds of
outputs they provide you with ultimately
leading to a interpretable
result okay so let's take a look here
at the final result of this analysis
you can hover over the individual dots
that represent samples
and you can see that they're colored in
four different uh in four different
colors there's the luminal which is pink
basil which is green normal like which
is blue
and cloud and low which are dark blue
now what is this box that we can spin
around
this is essentially a space
of defined by three principal components
the x y and z those are
axes on this in the space four
principal components selected by the top
information that they carry based on
how much percentage of variance
they show for our data and so just by
learning about these types of outputs
we can start asking questions about
similarity
and differences between these groups of
samples and
how we can actually take a
classification model
to train an algorithm
to identify the samples that we see here
based on feature significance based on
specific genes that are in this data set
and so going step by step through
examples
that you can run right here on the
screen
to more and more and advanced methods
you can see here going beyond the basics
we'll introduce some
additional applications of statistics
for example
to understand confidence levels on this
principal component
and eventually turning this into a data
science problem and the data science
problem is going to basically
tell us that i have a lot of data i have
mined
this data and i have identified some
differences between groups that i can
interpret
clinically using phenotypic information
and now i want to address a problem of
finding these types of subtypes
in a different data set and so now we
can
really translate this into a an
algorithm
that will look for specific markers that
will
identify those types of patients or cell
lines
that match a certain clinical phenotype
so as a brief introduction to data
science i think
this is a good example that shows us how
we can apply
this data-driven approach of data mining
classification training and machine
learning model
and asking the right kinds of questions
to
understand biology and to be able to
leverage
these signal points to really address
a major problem which is classification
of different types of cancers
especially based on biomarkers so
genes that we can detect and we can then
use
on big data to mine those patterns okay
so
if there are any other questions you can
go ahead and
put those questions in the chat box and
in the meantime
i would like to return briefly to our
uh presentation to talk about how
the other components are actually going
to be used
so as i mentioned
uh this is going to be a program
that combines live sessions like we have
today
where you can ask questions we can go
through code together and try to run it
maybe on our browser code playground or
maybe on your own computer
compare the outputs and be able to ask
specifically
whether we understand them with
self-guided study materials so materials
that you can then
practice online independently and
be able to validate that you can
actually go through these questions
go through the same types of challenges
and examples and then
receive practical assignments so in
these sessions we'll give you some
assignments
to complete so you can try it
practice it and then test whether you
really understand them
okay so at this moment i would like to
take a pause
and launch a poll so that we can get
a better sense of who's in this uh
session today
so uh so let me try launching the poll
okay so nanika if you could please
launch the poll it seems like it's not
possible from my computer
yes is the pool visible it's launched
from my side
yes i see people okay uh
yes so uh my first question is what is
your level of education
or in that matter what is your
designation are you a high school
student
an undergrad or a grad undergraduation
that means
bachelors graduation masters post
graduation
or a phd fellow or a postdoc fellow and
also i would want to know about your
research and trust so
uh what are your research interests
machine learning data science
infectious diseases or chem informatics
genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenetics
or the general bioinformatics and
also we would want to know if you have
signed up
on the omixlogic learn portal and
if yes it's great if not then we i would
be sharing the link with you and you can
go ahead with
signing up and creating your profile
thank you everyone for answering i would
keep the poll for more 30 seconds thank
you
okay thank you so much and um while
you're completing that
there's just a couple more things that i
wanted to share
okay so um what i wanted to
add on to this is that in the process of
getting started with data science but
also getting to a level of understanding
as we already heard from clinton
one of the highest levels of
understanding is when you can
meaningfully apply the methods and
skills that you have acquired
to a project where you can demonstrate
not just that you've memorized some
scripts but that you actually understand
how to extract meaningful signal
interpreted in biological
terms and be able to present it
answering questions to experts
and others peers like you so to do that
the omixlogic portal incorporates
several features that will help you do
just that the first one is that you will
gain access to these technical
skills that you can practice on given
examples but what if you want to try
an example of a different kind and so
the first thing
that i want to show you is that beyond
just the technical coursework
you will also have access to project
examples
and these include examples in cancer
they include different types
of data from cell lines from animal
models
as well as from patients that also
include some clinical
information you can also look for
infectious diseases where you will find
information on covid19 ebola virus
and others you will be able to find
many other types of examples that
include
agriculture biotechnology neuroscience
and many other examples
but beyond that all of the methods and
all of your activity on the site
is geared towards allowing you to
develop an independent project
and so to develop an independent project
i want to show you
the profile that you will have where
all of the activity that you will be
doing throughout the program
is going to link up into an opportunity
to track your own activity so you can
see where you are
and how expert level you are reaching
you're also going to see your progress
for the different
courses that you might be interested in
and taking
and then you will also be able to start
an independent project
so the independent project will require
you
to complete your profile with a
full picture and a brief bio about
yourself
so profile picture and a bio then you
will have to
reach at least 10 000 points where
you've demonstrated your skills and
abilities by practicing some of the
assignments
and taking different types of examples
from our repository of projects
and then finally you will be redirected
to
a course that we've prepared on how to
develop a bioinformatics research
project
so here we will give you some practical
guidelines
on how to choose a topic for your
project how to find
publicly available data if you don't
have your own data you can
take from the repositories that are
available online
and then how to translate what you have
identified as a topic and a data set
into a real research question and that
research question will have a
data component where you can apply your
data science skills
but also will include a clinical
biotechnology or pharmaceutical question
so a biomedical
question that you can answer with this
data and so
combining those two together you will be
able to
design a project presentation
and submit it for review by our team
that is managing this platform
this process will culminate in a
presentation
that you will be able to share with
others right under your profile
and to give you a sense of what these
projects look like
you will see down here on the front page
a few examples
of participants from high schools from
undergraduate level of college and
university education
as well as faculty that have completed
projects in a very short period of time
and were able to demonstrate how to
apply the methods that they have learned
to a data set and a topic of their
interests and how did they leverage it
to publish to present
a poster session to apply for jobs
or advance their research projects and
careers
and so i think that is really the
culmination of this program
is that we will be able to submit
a project proposal and if you choose to
stay long enough
you will be able to complete this
project
and actually come out with a full
project presentation at the end
so during this time we realized that
many of you are going to find it
challenging
processing big data on your laptop
and so what we are going to provide you
with is a 5 terabyte
storage space on our big data analysis
platform where you will be able to
utilize
big data analysis techniques to process
genomic transcriptomic metagenomic or
epigenomic data
and try some of the tools in a
user-friendly format so even before you
know any coding
you'll be able to understand how to
process visualize
analyze using statistical methods and
train machine learning models
using this interface that you don't
need any coding for this platform
combines many different types of data
that you can try
it also provides access to tools using
data mining
and importantly this will help you
practice
and identify the area and the type of
data
that you would like to focus on now
it includes a simple to follow
interface with explain methods
color-coded maps with different types of
inputs and
outputs that you can try and provide you
with a guided process
that is both interpretable reproducible
and following some standard applications
and outputs that you can directly use in
your final project
it covers things like sequence
alignments evolutionary studies using
phylogeny
variant calling rna-seq machine learning
and structure analysis beyond that
in the code playground you will find
tutorials on both
python and r just like what we saw
and many of the tools that you've done
on our visual
pipeline builder would be downloadable
as a code in r that you can right away
open up and start working through on
your computer
now some of the code is also going to be
in python and so we will have
a full session to introduce you to how
to
install and configure python on your own
computer
but also how to use some of the
exercises to start building up that
portfolio or library of useful scripts
that you can utilize
so we already talked about pca in r
you'll see the same is available in
python
and you will see that many of these
methods are going to be applied to a
variety of types of data
so that you can try genomic data
analysis as well as
transcriptomic epigenomic and
metagenomic types of data
now we will talk about how do you
learn the standard outputs but also
how do you then apply your data science
thinking
and solve problems right so it's not
going to be only
practicing some scripts it's also going
to be problem solving
once you acquire some of those skills
and that will include
finding the right piece of code from the
code that you've already practiced
or even writing some of the code on your
own so you can be more creative with
what you're going to be doing
okay so sorry about the uh
the date here seems to be outdated but
we're going to cover
this whole topic in two weeks
so these are essentially going to be two
big parts of the program
and they will cover an introduction
where we will learn about
the methods and the way these methods
are applied to specific
examples and then go through the
practical coding skills that you need
to continue working on these challenges
and as i mentioned
it will culminate in an independent
project
that will combine public domain data or
data that you have on your own
with methods that you have learned and
that you have
understood how they work to develop
essentially a novel
project proposal that will demonstrate
your ability
to work with different types of data and
extract meaningful insights and for that
we have a number of examples that we
will introduce you to
of how others have benefited benefited
from this
journey including some of the people
that already work
in research using some of these tools
and using some of the
skills that they have gained so we have
a number of different participants
they all have benefited from not only
the research component of this program
that allows you to really focus on
research questions but also from the
technical component
allowing you to practice these skills
and
receive guidance from mentors to be able
to solve
challenging problems in biomedical
research using
data science so for those of you that
are interested to join this program
again i recommend looking through some
of the resources that we've already
looked together at on this portal you
can always go back to the programs page
right here
and find the program is called lbrn
omnix logic data science so this program
is going to be starting on july 12th
so very soon and if you have any kind of
questions about this program or about
how to register
we recommend joining our session
like this so we will have a number of
webinars dedicated to this program
but also reach out directly to us we
have a marketing team
at marketing at pine.bio
and if you have any questions about
payments registration
if there are any discounts available to
different groups
uh depending on where where you are
located geographically
you can reach out to us with all of
those questions and
ask about certification ask about the
resources involved
or how to get in touch with mentors once
you are registered for the program
okay so i think that should give a good
overview of the
program itself if you do have any
questions
we have a minute or so to answer some of
the questions here
or as i mentioned you can easily reach
out to us
after the session as well and we'll be
happy to provide you with some of those
answers
and clinton did you if you wanted you
can add anything
else you would like to say to add to
this
i don't have you you're very
comprehensive i i don't
think i have any other thoughts
i do think this is a good way to
transition into a more analytical role
so
that would be my only point
all right thank you clinton and
everybody will have a chance to get to
know clinton
who is a great guy and uh very
knowledgeable
in data science in molecular biology
but also now in training and so we're
excited to have him
on board and help out with this program
and
we're excited for all of you to be able
to join the sessions that we are
planning to start
in july so if there are no other
questions for now
we will finish the webinar and we
welcome you to
uh explore the coursework and do let us
know if you're interested to join
between now and july 12th
and have a great rest of your day
thank you for joining clinton all right
and jasmine everybody else
thank you everyone for joining bye see
you in the second